i'm so down if you're if you're born a
male and you're like
i i decided i want to be a female so
call me she
alright cool the they them thing just
breaks my brain a little well because
because it sounds like i'm talking to
multiple people
the irony is right i'm a trans folk
right and people get upset and i'm like
bro i'm just telling you the truth i
have a genuine fear of trans people it's
confusing to me and it blows my mind and
they never go to the complete other side
enough to where even the ones that go
all the way over is just like
that's a lot for me you mean for my
brain something that that doesn't
it's just confusing i'm confused so
you're oh you're openly saying you're
transphobic yes okay i've said this
multiple times that people get mad at me
don't you mad at me cause i'm scared the
[ __ ] you want me to do i see that [ __ ]
have you had any conversations with any
trans people no and that's what i'm
trying to set up on my podcast cause i'm
trying to
have a better understanding i don't
think they're gonna kill me it's just a
scary thought the confusion worries do
you think being confused and being
scared or separate or kind of the same
because scared is like or tr you know
when we hear the word transform fear
means danger right so so the danger
would be right if
if
for most black men you would be worried
that you're going to run into a woman
that was a man
right that before previously right you
could have had the the johnson sliced
off could have got the breasts all the
female hormones but you still don't want
that to happen to you that's a big thing
i wouldn't want that to happen to me
that would bother me
so you want to have an open conversation
with someone who's from the trans
community i understand yeah because i do
think that there are people who
genuinely
decide like i'm not this and in order
for me to be happy and fulfilled i have
to live my life
this way and i respect that concept
completely and all of those other
concepts right the problem is when you
start trying to change what i see
that's my problem
so i think that the the
see that that's what i don't like
i think that like you're at least open
enough to where you can say i truly am
confused about what this is and have a
genuine fear and i genuinely would like
to sit down and have a dialogue with
someone sure who is from that community
because i would like to understand it
more yeah and i think that that is where
what you're saying
is different than
probably a lot of the hate and bigotry
and negativity that someone who is in
the trans community or someone who did
grow up
um as like maybe a trans 17 or 18 year
old
they experienced that word transphobic
in a different way that probably means
violence
hatred
you know their health being at risk you
know uh
discrimination
you're saying it in in terms of hey look
the actual definition really
this is a language thing it means you
know like you said danger fear right and
and i wouldn't say that you probably
fear for your life no but you don't
understand it sure and so you're i think
with yours because i don't want people
to be like glasses alone says he's
transphobic they can say that i'm a i'm
okay with being who i am and honest
about who i am but but what the
difference is is like with that word
comes and whether or not we like to
say this is what it says in the
dictionary with that word comes a lot of
other stuff attached to it so what being
i don't i don't think you're a bigot not
i would never hell no and i don't think
you're a hateful person
of course i hate some people and if i
haven't i don't think you're a hateful
person though i don't think you're i
don't think you're in your your first
nature is not being a hateful guy no but
but i don't think i don't think that's
even the worst racist concepts i think
it's all rooted in ignorance right we're
all ignorant
that's what i'm saying if you're scared
if you if you're arachnophobic right or
you have arachnophobia right you're
scared of spiders it's because you don't
understand you may think all spiders are
venomous you may think they could bite
you you may think all of that but if you
obviously right if you informed yourself
or if you were educated it would bring
some level of i also don't want to i
also don't want to compare spiders to
trans people because trans people aren't
poisonous they're just neither they're
just [ __ ] spiders but a lot of
spiders are not even a lot in the
majority aren't but but see how you just
did that see how see that's the thing
with human beings nobody trans is
poisonous but but again if if let's say
if it's a a man who was a woman
like a a man right who became a woman
right that's going out of her way
because there is some sleeping with guys
who she doesn't disclose that she is and
she know that could crush them that is
dangerous now i'm not saying that is
dangerous but i'm saying i don't
disagree with you but i'm saying that's
not all of their agendas just like with
spiders their agenda is not to poison
everybody so the part the point um that
you would like to try to understand in
sitting down with someone would be
some of the
i guess the concept of like why
why you're deciding to live your life
this way what is well i think i i get it
right
the idea of it makes sense to me right
okay if you really feel like even though
i could never relate i have no idea but
if if if you felt you are a woman your
whole life and you were a man and you
felt that way i don't think i want to
understand how did you feel that way i
don't think that's the point
um
which part of of it
is
is confusing to you that baffles you no
once it happens the fact that you want
me to see you different
that's the thing that [ __ ] me up so let
me ask you this right
if someone says to you
and i'm not saying cook on the couch
over there all of a sudden says hey i'm
a woman call me she or i'mma cancel you
right
but let's say you meet someone who's
let's say you grew up
around somebody you ain't seen them in
10 years yeah and you see them and
they've transitioned to a woman i'm not
thinking that this has happened because
it obviously hasn't happened now you
know that person
as however you know that person right
but but if they tell you hey look
glasses
it will make me feel
much better
it makes me
if you if you refer to me as this
if you refer to me as he or you refer to
me as my old name it hurts
it it it [ __ ] me up and and obviously
we can't tell anybody how to feel sure
pain is pain isn't that a minor
inconvenience
for you
to make someone feel alright
and i'm not saying it's your job to make
anyone feel all right well that's the
thing right i would do what's ever
convenient i would never just because as
much as i'm a transfer right which
i wouldn't go over i wouldn't walk up to
to to bruce
to caitlin rather i wouldn't call that
like i wouldn't i'm not going out of my
way back oh your mom named you bruce i'm
gonna name you i just i'm not right feel
me i just wouldn't even [ __ ] with that
person now if it's one of my best
friends i'm gonna call in whatever he
asking me to call him at or she's ever
asking me to call him at that point but
i would be uncomfortable why i'm
uncomfortable is is i don't quite know
i i don't know i'm being honest with you
i have no idea why it's almost crazy
because i'm
my fears is usually
i could you know see why but
you know this one is weird i'm not a
homophobe at all so when people call i
laugh
i think it's dope to just hear you say
that like you're open to having hey look
this is how i feel but i want to have a
conversation with somebody from the
community because but that's what my
podcast is all about